I'll be talking about
the work that we've
been doing to make sure that Big
Data Open Source software runs
smoothly and effectively
on Google Cloud Platform.
Now, I want to begin with
the big questions underlying
all of this, which
are what exactly it
means to run Big Data Open
Source software on Google's
Cloud, and secondly,
why that matters to you.
Now, imagine you have an awesome
idea for a web application.
Maybe you've been talking about
it for some time over lunch
and you decide to go for it.
You coded up over a weekend
and you hit the launch button.
Well as it turns out,
the rest of the world
thinks you're onto something.
So, you know somebody posts
an article out to Reddit,
a Slashdot article appears,
and before you know it,
you have a million
new users overnight.
So what happens?
Well, all too often, the
story ends right there.
Your server melts,
and your users quickly
lose interest in your
service unavailable site.
But, let's hit the
undo button, suppose
you went with Google App Engine,
and your app scaled seamlessly
just like you intended.
So now you have a
million happy new users.
So what's the next step?
Well, as it turns
out, life likes
to throw curve balls at you.
So you see bots and
spammers show up,
flooding your forums with junk
and driving your users away.
Now when you only
had like 10 users,
it was pretty easy to
just eyeball the logs
and ban a couple IP addresses
and be done with it.
But somehow as it turns
out, eyeballs just
don't scale to a million
users, and your computer now
refuses to load the terabytes
of log files that you now have.
So you might find yourself
reinventing the wheel.
You might write a
quick program just
to process those
logs automatically,
try to catch these spammers.
Maybe you'll find you need
to run on multiple machines,
so you'll write a controller
program to automate this.
So what began with a
day's worth of work
quickly ends up with
you just discovering
a week's worth of work.
And a week later, you're a month
behind, and in the meantime,
your website has
become a lost cause.
Well, let's hit the
undo button again.
What if you didn't have
to reinvent the wheel?
What if with just the
click of a button,
you had all the tools you
need to solve your spam
problem before
lunch and you could
spend the rest of the day
building the next killer app,
building the next feature for
the next 10 million users?
What if you really could scale
from a garage size to Google
Data Center size overnight?
As it turns out,
that's exactly what
running Open Source Big Data
software on Google's Cloud
is all about.
Now, just to get into
some of the mechanics
here of actually running
on Google's Cloud,
there are two big
pieces to this puzzle.
On the one hand, we
have making the most
of Google's
infrastructure offerings.
Now traditionally, if you've
invested heavily upfront
in a lot of hardware,
you'll end up
with all these machines of a
certain size, a fixed shape,
and all too
commonly, you'll find
yourself wasting endless time
and money building the software
to try to fit this
mold, trying to fit them
into this fixed shape.
In Cloud, we turn
this upside down.
So you should write
your software however
it feels natural, write your
software for your application
logic, and they get
the resources that
match your use case perfectly.
Perhaps the most egregious
example of a fixed shape
would be when you buy
hardware, the time dimension
is extremely rigid.
You end up with this
contiguous block
of time for your
on-premise hardware that
is unbroken between
the time you buy it
and the time you're
ready to throw it away.
Well in Cloud, why not just get
multiple disposable clusters
instead?
If you need to get some
data analytics done today,
why not run multiple
clusters, each analyst
gets their own cluster
to use by themselves,
and get your workload
done now instead
of having to wait in line.
The second piece
of the puzzle is
making most of Google's platform
rather than necessarily just
having to duct tape a bunch
of little components together.
And this is where
we've been doing work
to make sure that you
have all the tools
and libraries necessary to make
it one seamless experience.
We want you to be able to use
your open source tools, as well
as higher value Google
services, like BigQuery,
and mix and match and have
them interoperate seamlessly
on the same data.
Just to give an
idea of what this
looks like at a very
high level view,
let's go to the demo machine.
I'll explain a little more
about what's happening here
under the hood, but you just
to see what it looks like.
I'm going to go ahead and
deploy an 88 core cluster that's
fully loaded with
all the greatest data
analytics open source
software there is,
and-- I should actually
type a command--
and we'll see what happens
a little bit later.
So let's go back
to the slides now.
So, you might have
noticed Hadoop
was in the title
of the last slide,
and we really are talking
about all Big Data Open Source
software here.
But, just to give a little
bit of Hadoop context,
Hadoop has played a
crucial role at being
one of the very
first open source
implementations of
the MapReduce paradigm
and one of the first such widely
adopted software frameworks,
which ultimately provided
this fault tolerance
and the machinery necessary to
provide a really low barrier
entry to starting to make
use of large distributed
clusters of commodity hardware.
And this is really what
enabled Big Data to really go
mainstream and help it
mature to what it is today.
More recently, we
see Hadoop serving
in a crucial capacity as
a point of convergence.
So what I mean by
this is not quite
sitting down to
write RFCs, but what
we have is some organic
community consensus driven
convergence onto
certain behaviors
and certain interfaces
that came out of Hadoop.
And one specific
example of this,
is the Hadoop
distributed file system,
where we see that as
data and analytics grows,
as the ecosystem grows with
a diverse set of tools,
all of these tools are able
to promise interoperability
with your data simply by
virtue of implementing
the Hadoop distributed
file system.
And that brings
us to one product
that we have today available and
available for you to use now,
which is the Google Cloud
Storage connector for Hadoop.
This is built on top of the
aforementioned standardization
by implementing the Hadoop
File System Interface.
So what this allows is for
you to install this connector
onto your Hadoop
clusters and to replace
at least a portion, or
all, of your data access
needs using Google Cloud
Storage instead of Hadoop HDFS.
We provide tools for
automatically installing
and configuring this,
such that you can either
run in a hybrid mode,
so that naturally you
can take your time migrating
what data makes sense
to put on Google Cloud
Storage together with HDFS,
or for new batch workloads,
it might make sense just
to run without any
HDFS altogether.
We have screenshots, but
let's go to the demo machine.
Live is always better.
So let's go ahead, and we have
a Hadoop cluster open here
with the GCS
connector installed.
So what we'll see
here is-- let's
just create a file-- let's
echo here-- we'll just
say hi to Cloud and
create "hello.txt."
So we can see this file has
been created on my local laptop,
and we can go over
here to Google Cloud
console and-- nope,
not a new folder--
we want to upload this "hello"
file through our familiar GUI
interface.
And as we can see, this
is the cloud portion,
everything worked
just as we intended.
Now what we can do is we find
that we have the Hadoop file
system shell is available
in this Hadoop cluster
and we can just cut out
that exact same file-- OK,
I mistyped something
here-- and we
see that we can access that
same file the same way we would
through the Hadoop file
system shell, as we would
through the GCS GUI, as we would
through the GCS command line
tool, gsutil.
So let's return to the slides.
So to summarize
what we've seen, we
have two axes of
interoperability here.
On the one hand, we have
Cloud interoperability,
where we have the same
access and the same behavior
from all different
cloud services.
Importantly, this also means
the same access for other Google
Cloud services like
BigQuery, which
can interoperate by sharing
GCS as the common data storage.
The second axis is
Hadoop interoperability,
as we talked about, where we
can unlock a really broad range
of open source tools just
by virtue of implementing
this standard Hadoop
file system interface,
and that includes making GCS
work with Pig, Hive, Spark,
Shark, and numerous other
open source technologies.
What this ultimately means for
you is a significant reduction
in operational
overhead because now
your data is not tied to
any single location in terms
of some set of
disks, nor is it tied
to any particular
technological stack.
So if you're tired
of MapReduce and you
want to try something new,
your data's still there.
You can start processing
it in a new framework.
Now, when the question arises
of whether something like GCS
can really be a feasible
replacement for HDFS,
performance often comes up.
And I think there is really two
real aspects to this question.
First is the question of whether
the networking technology is
really progressing in the right
direction, such that doing
this would be feasible.
And secondly,
there's this question
of relinquishing a little bit
of that fine grain control
that you might otherwise
have with HDFS.
Little things like
rack locality,
or replication policies.
And I'm reminded of the
first time I actually
had an opportunity to write
a lot of assembly code.
I remember I was really
excited going into it
because it was this
opportunity to try out
all the clever hacks I'd always
wanted to make it run fast.
And it turns out, after
the novelty wore off,
it was actually fairly painful
writing all this assembly code.
But I do remember
after so many hours
of muttering at the screen,
getting it to finally work
the way I wanted, and
getting a huge success,
it was like 20% percent speedup.
I later found out, sadly, that
if only I had flipped the "-03"
flag on GCC, the original
program already would have ran
twice as fast.
Now what I learned,
aside from the fact
that maybe I'm not
the assembly guru
I had hoped I was, was I
learned to trust the compiler.
I learned to trust the decades
of experience, of expertise
from compiler experts
that have gone into it.
Whenever Java happens
to be the right tool,
I feel rest assured knowing
that my memory management is
actually in pretty good hands.
And when I use
Google Cloud Storage,
I know I'm taking advantage
of an incredible amount
of research and development that
has gone into Google's storage
technologies over the years.
And Google Cloud
Storage still might not
be the right tool for every
use case, but what's important
is simply having the option
to take a step back, let
somebody else handle
all the dirty,
grungy work, because
that's ultimately
how you can let magic happen
while you focus on building
the features and products
that you actually care about.
Now that said, earlier this
year the technology consulting
company Accenture
actually released
a study of the performance
characteristics
and the total cost of
ownership trade off
between on-premise
deployments of Hadoop,
as compared to Hadoop
on Google Cloud.
I'd encourage anybody interested
to read the whole paper.
It's quite in-depth with a
lot of different dimensions
of analysis.
But what we have here is
at least one sample out
of that paper showing a
realistic real-world workload
where we have the red bars
here showing a mixed data flow
model, where we use the
GCS connector for the input
and output of the initial and
final stages of the MapReduce,
still using HDFS as
an intermediate store,
as compared to the
blue bars, which
are just using a
local disk HDFS.
And we see that we actually
had a pretty encouraging speed
up using the GSC
connector-based data flow model.
The green line here at the
top is the benchmark value
of the bare metal
Hadoop deployments
from a total cost of
ownership analysis,
and we can see that
across all dimensions,
the Cloud deployments
outperformed.
So lower values are better here.
So I'm happy to
announce that we've also
been working on two other
Hadoop connectors for connecting
to Google Cloud services.
We hope that the
data store connector
will help you bring data
analytics through open source
tools to operate
on the same data
that you use in your web
serving, or that you generate.
And we hope that the
BigQuery connector will
help aid the seamless
interoperability between,
whether you started
out just using BigQuery
and want to use
open source tools,
or if you started out
with open source tools
and want to start
using BigQuery,
you should be able to go
either way seamlessly.
Both of these we hope to
make available publicly
in early April.
Along with all these
connectors, we also
have a thin helper tool called
bdutil, which helps deploy
and install all
this Hadoop software
with the thin
extensibility mechanism
for customizing your software
and mixing in more open source
tools.
And that brings us to what we'll
demo here using bdutil of Shark
on Google Cloud Platform.
Now Shark is a prime example
of how all this open source
technology works together and
works well with Google's Cloud.
Shark is ultimately-- is
basically Hive on Spark.
Where Hive is the SQL on
Hadoop, so the Hive engine
will translate SQL
over unstructured data
into MapReduces
that run in Hadoop.
Whereas Spark is an entirely
different data processing
model then MapReduce,
but here we
have Shark implementing
total compatibility
with Hive queries, but
instead of using MapReduces
under the hood,
it will use Spark.
And we'll see how this
plugs into Google Cloud
Platform in two ways.
First, by reading your
external data from GCS,
so that your data can
persist independently
of persisting your
compute cluster.
And secondly, by
plugging into Cloud SQL
so that you can have
multiple different clusters,
all plugged into Cloud SQL as
your metadata store and reading
from that.
So we'll go to the
demo machine now.
And we see that so
far-- well, first,
let's launch a cluster, bdutil.
And we ran something similar
to this already, but just
to elaborate a little
bit, what we have here is
an extension that
I've created here
that's just for installing
Shark on Cloud SQL.
And all it does-- here
are some shell scripts
that actually
install Shark, we'll
provide some cluster
specific configuration,
and we just kick it off.
If we take a look at our cluster
specific configuration here,
we see that we have some
basic settings like number
of workers, a prefix for
the cluster name that all
our instances will have, which
project to use, and so on.
Since we are lucky
enough to kick off
a cluster a few moments
ago in this presentation,
we can go ahead and just use
that as our other cluster.
Take a look inside.
So we'll run as Hadoop.
And let's go ahead and boot up
a Shark command line, a Hive M
line, and maybe
another Hive command
line on the second cluster--
figure all of these out here.
So we can see we don't
have any tables yet.
Now we can go ahead-- I
happen to have a data set here
of a natality birth-data
data set for the year 1970
through today, and it
happens to be in Avro format.
So this is just some
files sitting in GCS,
and what we'll do is we'll
create an external table, which
is this pointed at that.
So now that that
has been created,
we see that it appears
in both Shark and in Hive
on the same cluster and in
Hive on the other cluster.
So you can see this is demo two
down here and demo one up here.
And sure enough, we
can also select top 10
from it from any of
these three shells.
So suppose we want
to find out if there
are any trends in the
number of underweight births
as a fraction of the
total number of births
over the years.
So, here's a query that
we have prepared here.
And we'll just
plug it into Shark.
Now while that
kicks off, suppose
we also have
another set of data.
Here's a common
use case, suppose
we have a bunch of
files in JSON format.
So people often use JSON formats
as an initial data format,
but it's usually good to get
a binary format, like Avro.
So, we can go ahead and
create this JSON table
in our second cluster.
And then what we'll do is we'll
use Hive as our data conversion
engine here simply by creating
a second table in Avro format
and then just saying select
star out of our JSON table
and writing it into
our Avro table instead.
We'll do that in
our second cluster.
And now we can take a
look at the web UIs here.
So here I have a web UI open
of the built-in Spark GUI,
and we can see all the
commands that we just ran.
We ran select, and it looks
like it's already finished,
the Shark query that we
kicked off a little while ago.
And if we go into our
second cluster, demo two,
and open the Hadoop
console, we can
see that Hive has gone ahead and
translated that second query,
that JSON creation
query, into a MapReduce.
So now we have MapReduce
running on some data that's
in GCS, right next to
Shark running against Spark
on other data that
was also in GCS.
And we can see that, sure
enough, we got the results.
We see that over the
'80s, the percentage
of underweight births
went down a little bit
and then seemed to
go up as we came
out of less prosperous
years apparently,
so some very interesting data.